so
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
thank you
okay
all rise for the new session
okay um please be seated we did contact
the county and um they are going to
adjust the temperature remotely for us
so it should be okay we do need to close
those outer doors
just before being literally
this video is a little bit dark on the
projections
so now we're going to be in the dark
it's another facility
[Music]
yes we talking about the light yeah no
about this the picture oh he was up
there already
right but that just happened where it
was done like that
yes
that doesn't really help you much
doesn't
as long as the court can see it right
which exhibitor is that this is 30.
it's a 10-second clip there's a 31 is a
brighter video so i'm going to do this
10 seconds
did it happen after you hook back up
no this is just the way it's just our
video okay go ahead and try it and if
it's an issue then we have to get
uh to the court in the flash drive as
well if she's a corporate viewer
i don't know if i can do it on this one
you're really testing my electronics
all right let's go ahead and try and if
not then
all right i'll go ahead and proceed you
think we're back on recordings okay
detective we were at exhibit 30.
um
now there were on the test drive we're
referring to between ethan and crumbling
the other juvenile at 25 000 or so text
thread there were videos included that
you viewed yes sir okay specifically on
um august the 19th of 2021 did you view
a video on that text message thread yes
sir and that was a video sent from ethan
crumbley to that other person yes sir
to make sure we're referring
yesterday this is august the 19th of
2021 and it appears to have a
person holding a handgun is that correct
correct yes sir okay that noise that we
heard in the end
what was that they uh the person hit the
slide lock release so the slide went
forward
did you also review a video in the same
text throughout the same conversation
shortly after that one was sent in the
early morning hours of august 20th
yes sir this
is 31.
that's correct
again this was sent from ethan crumley
to that other individual is that correct
correct yes sir
now sir
i'm going to back this up just a little
bit
you're 25 years as a police officer
you've obviously handled firearms that
correct yes sir okay and you've seen um
the ammunition for firearms yes sir okay
and you know how to properly load a
handgun yes sir okay tell me what's
happening in this video
he inserted the magazine into the
magazine well and you could see the top
of one of the bullets
right here
yes sir okay does that mean there's a
round in the chamber
soon as that slide goes forward there
will be okay
and prior to this point of the video
this is at
the very beginning of the video what is
this object right here that appears to
be vertical on the
counter cup that's a handgun magazine
okay and what's in the handgun magazine
those are bullets
let me play that again so we can see it
that was 31. sir were there was there a
text message conversation in the midst
of these videos being sent yes sir okay
so this is people's 32 and in like
people's 29 we made some changes to the
redaction so this would be a new copy
for the court
defense kansas as well
and sir once you take a look at it could
you please tell me if this is in the
same text thread that we had emitted uh
people's 29 which is the text message
start between ethan crumbly and that
other juvenile yes sir
and what is the date and time of the
first text message on that piece of
paper there the first message is a video
8 19 20 21
at 9 31 p.m okay and that's the video
that we watched in people's 30. yes sir
okay people move to emit exhibit 32.
no objection
okay thank you
green is um the owner again is that
correct yes sir okay and it has the
phone number where it's sent to and he
said this attachment the video was sent
august 19th 2021 at 9 31 pm correct okay
i'm sorry i have the same one
one moment please
here we go
okay okay then we have a response to
that video being sent what is that
response the response from the other
juvenile is nice okay and there's
spelled
correctly or no there's a couple extra
eyes and i i i see okay
and then what was the message from ethan
crumbly
ethan then says shoot that sunday
question mark and that's august the 19th
2021 at 9 34 p.m correct yes sir
okay the next text
he even says if you don't want to come
to the range to the gun range that's
fine you can just tell me no hard
feelings okay any response to that
the other juvenile states nah
i do but it's just kind of hard for me
to ask
rn what's rna mean
right now okay
any response
um okay
and that was sent in august 19th 2021 at
1106 p.m correct okay
uh response
next next text please from the other
juvenile was sorry okay
and then what did ethan crumbly write
it's okay
and the following text is an attachment
is that right correct yes sir that
attachment is a video correct yes sir
and
um am i correct it's august the 20th
2021 at 12 30 a.m correct yes sir okay
and that's the video that we saw in
exhibit 31 yes sir okay
and then the other person's
response
nice again misspelled with three eyes
okay and please continue reading
the other juve then states now pull the
trigger
jk jk jk jk
and then there's it doesn't appear to be
any response in this text bubble from
ethan crumbly to that person is that
right correct all right the next text
please
my dad left it out so i thought quote
why not lol and what time do you write
my dad left it off so i thought why not
it's at 12 32 a.m on the morning of the
20th august 20th
okay
and there's no response here correct
correct
all right and then what did ethan
crumbly write
he responds with
ik i know
gun safety so it's no problem
please continue
ethennes says now it's time to shoot up
the school
in the final text in this export jk jk
jk jk jk okay that was sent from ethan
crumley to this other individual august
the 20th 2021 at 12 34am is that right
correct yes
now
you reviewed this entire text message
thread between ethan crumley and that
individual is that right correct yes sir
and we have talked about the number of
text messages that printed out be over i
think you said 25 000 pages that right
yes sir was there a time when this text
message history just abruptly stopped
yes sir and when was that
it was
middle around october
around halloween time i believe is when
it was that's 2021 yes sir i'm sorry
okay
now sir
during the review of the data extraction
on ethan crumbly's phone what else did
you observe known
uh there was text messages back and
forth between the other juvenile and him
of
kidnapping and killing another classmate
there's also videos of killing and
mutilating baby birds
okay anything else
um
not that i can recall well sir are you
able to look at his web history yes sir
okay now i don't want to name the
website but was there a particular um
on his web searching history are you
able to identify a particular website
that he identified that he visited quite
often yes sir okay and just to give us
an idea how many times did he
visit that particular site in the month
of november of 2021 421 times
and what were sort of some of the sort
of things that he was searching it was
very graphic content it dealt with other
school shootings particularly ones in
florida
and people being killed okay now we've
talked a lot about
you know this was ethan crumley's phone
jennifer crumbly's phones james truman's
phone et cetera
were you able to determine who actually
owned ethan crumbly phone yes sir and
who was that uh james crumbly was the
owner on all the accounts okay and he
paid the bills yes sir
hey one moment
detective uh during the course
during the course of your investigation
did you come to learn that there was
more than one gun in the crumbly home
yes sir okay so we've been referring to
the nine millimeter sick that was a
firearm used in the actual shooting am i
right correct yes sir okay what were the
other firearms found in the coming house
there was a caltech i believe
i believe it was
a 22 caliber
and then there was a small um derringer
okay now the videos that we saw in
people's 30 and 31 that what kind of gun
is that if you can tell
that was the caltech 22 caltech yes sir
and that's also semi-automatic yes sir
thank you i have nothing for you
yes
okay
yes just keep your voice up okay
um good afternoon good afternoon ma'am i
want to go back to
um exhibit 29
and really what i need to do is have you
help me understand
the reports
when you take stuff off of a celebrate
report
it's fair to say there's different ways
you can extract the information is that
correct
well
to be precise
take information off the the data that
the from the phone and then export
reports from that data yes
okay and when you testify that if if
messages are deleted
um sometimes those will not come up in
the report is that correct they won't
come up in the extraction the
analyzation of the data yes ma'am okay
so
your honor um
yeah
okay may i approach the witness with
these materials
it's like materials
um these are the texts between ethan and
the other young man that we've been
discussing
on the record
they're not
they're not
they're not exhibits at this point
okay so you just need to make sure
they're identified correctly as well
okay
so
this is all one
this is all
there's two separate files but i'm gonna
ask you about that
okay so detective i just handed you a
very large stack of papers
and
if you take a quick skin through it it
appears to be the all of the messages
between ethan crumbly
and his friend
who were not identifying on the record
name starts with b
does that does that appear true to you
that looks quite yes ma'am okay so at my
office when i get your celebrate report
um i pulled up all of these messages
printed them and brought them into court
today and if every page is there you
would agree with me that that's from the
celebrate report is that a fair
statement
it came from it's a celebrate report yes
ma'am i can tell you that because the
logo is on there it looks like it should
i don't know if it were you're asking is
it every message that they shared back
and forth well no i there'd be nowhere
to verify that because there's so many
thousands um i'm i'm just asking
if i'm telling you that i printed those
off celebrate does that
does that look like what you would
expect to look like yes ma'am it does
okay
so i want to turn your attention to
exhibit 29 which was admitted when the
prosecution was um
questioning you your honor may i
approach the witness
i have exhibit 29 29 yes
okay and exhibit 29 contains a series of
text messages
that were from april
2021.
yes ma'am
okay and those messages specifically um
that were admitted in exhibit 29
those messages
did not print when i printed the
messages so
i'm wondering if you can explain why
the printouts i printed from celebrate
would be missing those some of those
messages without having where you
printed that from to be able to examine
myself there's no way i can tell you
that
okay is it possible that those messages
were deleted by the user of the phone
no if it was in there if it was in the
original data that was given to you it
doesn't matter if it was deleted it
would still show it would still be there
there is not
as far as you know there is not a way
to filter out
um
dates if you print the entire thing as a
whole correct
printing the entire thing as a whole
from the first text to the last if
that's what this is then that's what
should be there yes
and
can you
take a look at the texts i printed from
4
5 of 21
and can you show me where
the texts on exhibit 29 fall into that
where they where they would be
has testified to the exhibits that we've
admitted because he actually exported
them using the celebrate software this
was just handed to him five minutes ago
i didn't print out point five thousand
text messages because i'm not going to
admit 25 000 text messages there's just
no way for this officer to know that
that is in fact the entire text threat
between ethan crumbling and other person
but she's certainly ask him about his
particular date and if it doesn't edge
up it doesn't match up in in what smith
is handed but we just don't know
we have an expert in cell phone
forensics because it takes some skill to
actually extract some of this ability
and take some expertise which he has so
we just don't know it could quite
frankly just be use your error we don't
know if that is actually the
representative text thread the entire
text thread there's no way to know from
a paper and your honor in all honesty
accuracy in getting things right is
what's important in this case making
sure that it's accurate
i don't understand why all of the texts
are missing many texts that the
prosecution is using
i'm trying to understand that but to be
quite frank i asked this court to
adjourn so that we can explore this
issue and figure this out this is a very
big deal that we are we do not have
these texts for clarification are you
asking him
to identify
whether or not
the exhibit is the entire string of the
text thread
i can't have him because he didn't print
that out
i all i can say is i printed it out as
the entire screen
does it i i can ask does it appear to be
the entire set of text messages
so you are
are you asking him to identify where
exhibit 29 page one calls in yes where
those exhibits are yes and they're in
order by date so
detective if you could go to april
uh yeah if i could just
go
um
[Music]
there's one thing that i just stand i
don't know again
um if these are the the messages the the
file path the source info that this came
from that this right here is different
than the source info here they should be
the same i don't know why that is
but i'll look for the text messages
where they should be in here
from just look it should be this is the
first one that i see for april 5th
in this stack
and the next one
i'm sorry stan let me just apologize
it shows
april 5th there 3 54 a.m and then
3 17.
so
somewhere with in between
these two dates these two messages right
here
so so i mean just for clarification for
my own purposes when i'm looking at
exhibit number 29 for the date of april
i show
eight bubbles of conversation
anywhere from 12 38
am through
12 39
a.m
are you able to identify those bubbles
in the standard materials that she did
no ma'am no no ma'am
okay your honor um i know this court
heard our motion to adjourn earlier
today
council
co-counsel and i have been dealing with
thousands and thousands of pages we are
very clearly missing pages that are
being admitted as evidence in this case
i ask the court to adjourn and give us
an opportunity to look into this issue
this is a very big deal
if they're admitting a few pages
and we don't have those in what's the
entire printout that
and that's happened with a couple of
sections of it that's a big problem for
the defense so they're not missing
anything
this detective took the same program the
same evidence that we have at the
prosecutor's office we turned over to
defense
she just didn't find it in the evidence
that's been given to her and this
detective can testify to that what he
did exactly to export this he just
testified that the final path is
different the source file if you export
and i don't want to testify myself
that's why we have an expert oh that's
why you have the expert message
how would you obtain this information
so you certainly can cross-examine him
on that at this
how did you
obtain how did you go through rotating
the information that's on exhibit 29
within the whole
the whole uh
chat thread text thread you would
uncheck every call every
message going back and forth and just
check the ones you want and then just
export as a pdf
so it's your testimony that you
you went from
all of the text messages
and i picked out the ones you want to
check those off and printed those out is
that correct and separate reports yes
ma'am
and so if my office printed out all the
messages and we printed them out
correctly
those messages should be in my complete
stack if printed correctly yes ma'am
your honor i am asking the court to
adjourn they are printed correctly and
we are missing messages
and if if this is user error or an issue
this is something that needs to be
determined
long rise
court is in recess
okay
due to the voluminous nature of the
exhibits of the victim we are not likely
to finish with this witness today we're
going to go ahead and
continue the exam
on february 24th
starting at 8 30 a.m
it's necessary for the court to add an
additional day after the 24th after the
24th we'll revisit that issue on that
daily time however i am indicating to
all parties that i am cleared that day
specifically for this case so we will
have the full day
as far as exhibits go
prosecutor
take all original exhibits with you
um everybody has their copies
and your
technology
i just want to place on the record that
when we were in chambers the
defense council identified two witnesses
we asked about if one of those witnesses
is not going to be called we just ask
them to give us a notice so we can
subpoena that witness to you here
sure
thank you the prosecution said they get
back to us no problem so thank you okay
thank you
thank you
foreign
so
[Music]
thank you